in the last video we talked about Sobel
edge detection okay so the so will
operate you is a kernel convolution
process we can use and it returns a high
response where there's a sharp change in
gradient of image and a low response
where there isn't it's generally run on
grayscale images that we first blur just
to make sure if things nice and smooth
it also handily produces an orientation
at every point in our image which tells
us from north in image upwards to
downwards left and right what direction
is our edge facing and that can be
really useful for sort of
post-processing this image so that's
what we're going to talk about now the
canny edge detector is essentially take
the Sobel operator and makes it just a
step better or step more useful perhaps
for image analysis which is to get rid
of the edges that we're not really
interested in and keep our lead a really
good stuff the canny edge detector was
published in 1986 and the input of a
canny operator is simply the output of
sober okay so we've taken our image
we've converted to grayscale we've run
our Gaussian blur and then we've won our
Sobel operator in both the X and y
directions we've calculated the gradient
and the orientation of those and that's
when we're ready for Cannings process
okay it's fairly simple but of course
it's also effective and so it still sees
a lot of use there are other newer edge
detectors and there are certainly a lot
of newer filters that used instead of
Sobel but so bill still sees a lot of
use canny works by taking the image from
a Sobel output thinning all of the edges
so they're one pixel wide okay because
thick edges doesn't really help us what
we really care about is where are the
edge is not how thick are they imagine
we're trying to find the centerline of a
route okay because we want to find where
the route is if we do a Sobel edge
detection it's going to find gradients
at both the left and the right side the
route it's going to be a bit messy but
also it's not resolution independent if
we've got a really high-resolution image
the grading is going to be spread over
many pixels in a low resolution image
you're going to have a very sharp edge
gradient because that's the best that we
can do with those of those pixels
what the canny edge detector does is get
rid of all that and just say this is
where your edges because I've got rid of
all the stuff on the outside of it canny
works by first filling the edges and
then we use a process called hysteresis
fresh holding which sees using of
which is essentially a two-level
threshold which I'll talk about okay so
the first thing to do for every pixel is
try and find out if it's a local maximum
okay that means that it is bigger than
its neighbors okay sounds easy but we
also bear in mind the orientation it was
produced by so well so for every part of
the image if this is our image and we
were examining let's say this pixel here
okay
we've run our Sobel x and y operators on
it and we've got a value of GX and Gy
and we've got a value of the magnitude
of this edge now the magnitude of this
edge might be smaller or larger and what
we want to do is try and find out if X
is bigger than its neighbors we really
only care about whether X is bigger than
its neighbors across the edge right if
along the edge yes it might be getting
bright or smaller but that's not really
what we're concerned with so basically
if the edge is traveling down in this
direction then we really care if X is
bigger than this one and this one okay
if the edge is traveling in this
direction then we really care fix is
bigger than this one on this one all
right so what Kenny does is say what's
for your orientation of our edge based
on the output of a Sobel operator
remember could we use inverse tan to
find that and then given that is it
bigger than its neighbors and doing that
over the whole image will produce lots
of very nice thin edges right at the
peaks of the center of our virus bonds
so if you've got a gradient on your
roots or on your whatever on the edge of
the flower the petal or whatever it's
basically just going to find the
strongest yeah so if we imagine looking
at the gradient from the side then you
might find a solo response looks a bit
like that okay because it's a kind of
shallow edge you know it's brightest
where it is most deep but because a
photograph or something maybe it's not
completely steep okay and what can he
does is scrap all this and just get an
edge right in the center okay and that's
really what we want okay
so that's the first process the second
stage is to remove the edges that even
bovver a local maximum they're still not
very useful to us because maybe they're
really weak response so noise basically
right we want to create an image of the
dominant edges owned and preserve only
the dominant edges for that we use a
process called hysteresis fresh holding
so let's imagine that we've run our non
maximal suppression over the whole image
okay so we have lots of nods individual
lines of pixels
okay that's great but how do we fresh
hold them to decide what edge is
important to what edge isn't so if we
pick just a threshold let's say all the
edges go from nought to 255 so naught is
no edge two five five is about the
strongest edge you can imagine okay what
value do we pick that's a good edge
right if we pick a value of 20 most of
the edges are going to be in right which
means you're going to get a lot of noise
a lot of nonsense and if you're looking
for the football in their picture
there's gonna be a lot of other stuff
you have to weed out before you can work
out where the ball is but then if we
pick a high threshold like 200 we're
going to get the edge of the ball maybe
we might start to lose some of it
because not all of the edges are going
to be as strong just sort of just how it
is all right so let's show you
hysteresis first holding in one
dimension first and then you'll see how
it applies to an image so if this is our
one dimensional image okay and we have
an edge response over here it's pretty
good and we have an edge response over
here which is really good and then no
edge response over here now if we were
fresh holding just by a single level if
we put this level here then we're going
to get this top area we're not going to
get this area over serious and that
might be okay but we might want this one
okay because this is kind of part of the
same object perhaps that we want to try
and preserve so hysteresis thresholding
will have a threshold here and a
threshold here anything above the top
fish hold is automatically okay so we
take all this and this is already okay
anything below the bottom threshold is
automatically discounted it's not strong
enough response that's probably not an
edge we're interested in okay so we take
off here and this is all got rid of and
when anything between the two thresholds
is only preserved if it's connected to
something above the top threshold okay
so we're trying to sort of continue
along edges where we've already had a
high response at some point okay so
maybe this idea football is really good
and the other side is not so good
but because it's connected you think yes
probably okay part of the same object so
this stuff gets included simply by being
connected to this high official in two
dimensions it works the same way we look
around the image and we search for edges
and any edge verts above our top fish
hold we automatically include and any
edge that's connected to it via pixel
traversing we automatically include
everything else we Square and that
really preserves only the sort of the
core edges of the image the stuff that
really shows you what shape everything
is
and then you could maybe do some other
post-processing to find objects or
something with that so I should probably
show you some images now I've grabbed an
album again I haven't coded up Kenny
because there's a lot of good
implementations of Kenny out there takes
a little bit of time to to traverse an
image okay if you're looking for an
implementation be OpenCV one is very
good okay and you can use OpenCV in Java
and C++ and Python as far as I know okay
so what Kenny does is it takes our Sobel
operator and using the orientation of
each edge it thins it and then it does
history's first holding to find the sort
of dominant edges and you get a picture
that looks much like what it did before
but now we've really just got the
outline of the flower almost the entire
edge of the flower and it's leaf have
been preserved but we've lost a lot of
stuff between the petals so we can
obviously adjust both the lower and
upper threshold of the hysteresis fresh
holding and the sort of noisiness of a
Sobel operator by blurring and both of
those will have an effect and we can
really control what edges come out of
cannae we can have just a few really
dominant edges or quite a lot of edges
if that's what we want here is an edge
fairly obviously we can see that but a
computer card so if we put our Sobel
operator here then what we're
essentially doing is doing 100 times 1
plus 100 times 2 plus 100 times 1